[Musique]
tu vis dans une société aujourd'hui eux
j'ai des gens ils font médecine et et
ils font dix ans d'études et gagne 3 4
mille balles par mois après des années
d'études ou on te dit c'est la voie
royale c'est faire médecine ils ont
passé des concours ils ont fini dans les
premiers et fait état des meufs qui
montrent leur cul sur instagram et
prendre quarante cinquante mille balles
par mois est de plus en plus tu vois ça
et comme tous les parents je suis
démunis c'est quoi le juste milieu
c'est que c'est quoi le juste milieu
dans cette société où on valorise de
plus en plus le paraître le manque de
travail le tout tout de suite c'est
qu'est ce que tu dis parce que il faut
être malgré tout compétitifs envie de
les protéger des réseaux sociaux mais
aujourd'hui les réseaux sociaux c'est
l'outil de travail quasiment le plus
importante voie de communication
non
[Musique]
hu
ok go voire
choquer
mais
on est sur un créneau où massa pour
midas et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non aux lettres qu est ce qu est ce qu
on me l'a pas dit vas-y vas-y passif et
celui-ci
s'est garé